[Music]
a guy going around asking other guys if
they lie to girls on socials about their
height
yeah i did see like four seconds of this
um
yeah i saw one where the guy just said
rags yeah there's a part one and there's
a part two oh okay gang five seven
seven five seven
oh they read it up don't they five seven
have either of you lied about your
height to a female 100
100 percent
so i said what are we talking what you
been telling the girls the most the most
the most i ever said yeah yeah yeah
it depends on what shoes i have on yeah
i've said six foot before
but we never met her in it so she would
never know
okay so how tall are you actually i'm
five eleven
five seven five five seven i'm five five
nine and a half five nine and a half
five seven yeah yeah man okay listen
boys we have got a tape measure my heart
who hurts
my heart in that moment i say turn the
camera off
i told you so you were no no
you have seven bro you're five six
five
[Laughter]
bro
there's a part two as well yeah so
there's another brother have you ever
lied to a female about your height
that's a healthy night yes i have yeah
yeah yeah yeah of course i think
everyone every man does yeah do they
yeah everyone adds an extra couple of
inches you know they always help yeah
one inch wondering
are you talking about height all right
yeah
of course of course oh
[Music]
at least one inch yeah of course yeah so
maybe six i've never had air force in my
life it does doesn't it
listen look we can actually put that to
the test okay we've got a tape measure
oh wow you're putting me on a spot like
that
understand what this would do to my
chest he is apparently six foot so let's
see if he's telling the truth okay yeah
he's not gassing me
yeah pretty much hang on yeah there you
go
um
[Music]
you seem a little bit taller
oh
bro he said fam he said i'm 5'4 he said
you're 5'4 he said hey yeah yeah what's
up
what's up what's up say something say
sorry i'm [ __ ] 5'4 what do you want
to say to me man got drawn out and he's
own thing
peak yeah ma'am um
dm's oh dms comments have you ever lied
about your height madam have you ever
lied about your height yeah to the gym
tall gal have you ever lied about your
height and said you're short than you
are oh because some girls get insecure
about being tall i'm not surprised i'm
not surprised and i think they're only
well not the only reason they're getting
secure i think one of the main reasons
why they're getting secured because a
lot of mandem aren't
like cutting it height wise for them
like the average like
yeah we've already discussed like a five
nine or five eleven females it's like a
six foot two if you're a female and
you're five eleven you're six six like
you're for something you're the tallest
your body is just elongated and
stretched and it doesn't make sense yeah
your your spiritual pressure is
different
your nan
your aura is matte
you're five eleven and you're a female
your aura's next yeah yeah she casts a
shadow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's impossible that's too tall that's
far too tall for a woman um so yeah i've
have you ever lied about your height
i don't
i might have
but i wouldn't say in like the last
ever probably since i've left uni i
don't think i've lied about my height
i'll swear i don't think so i've never
lied about my height i don't think i
might have like
back in it probably when i didn't even
know my height as much and i was
guestimating
so maybe i have but in the last
10 years or so i don't i'm pretty sure i
have never lied about my height
i've never lied about my hair i got i've
been challenged twice challenged fam
by my own like boys oh really i've been
challenged multiple times about my
height yeah once from my brother
at once from my boy you're a similar
height now you and your brother bro i
think he's a bit taller a little bit
taller yeah i think he's still 5 11. he
i reckon he's six foot but um
his hair's a bit longer so maybe that
that definitely helps but i think yeah
he calls himself 511 but i'm pretty sure
he's a bit taller than me okay um but
yeah i've been called out twice by
mandom of draws for tape measure because
they're adamant i'm sure
i don't know what it is about my posture
people talk about the gal i'm certain
that makes them tall yeah i have
something that makes me look shorter
than i am same
my
torso
just seems like very compact
to be fair it does
you've got a very compact also very
compact so
the rest of it it just [ __ ] up the rest
of my body bro
they're satin about when you look at me
there's sight and about that gives off
short vibes because my own brethren
draws my tape measure in my face i said
prove it have they prove it
and i've had to prove them wrong
multiple times wow and i won't stand for
it again in my life
you believe me or you don't believe me
but that was when 511 was an appropriate
thing to say yeah that was like i'm
talking here like 18 19 20. okay i was
allowed to say i'm 5 11. i feel good
about myself i was allowed to say i was
allowed to say that yeah now for so much
bother measuring me now because like
well you're still under six foot so it
doesn't even matter yeah i won't waste
time and measurements on you
i won't waste precious centimeters on
you you're not you're not even claiming
to be six foot why would i waste my time
you're not even cutting it you're
literally not even cutting it yeah you
have to meet a minimum of for me to
challenge you you have to at least say
you're six foot then i will challenge
you
but yeah bro people the sudden people
look at me and even we've had it when
i've been with you on the amount of
people that are like you've heard of the
same height i refuse to i'm like but
we're not we actually aren't
fam you are
all right but i don't care my man when
we went to uh last october we went to um
at the festival we went to a um comedy
festival a podcast festival and a few
people came down to actually see us live
for the first time kind of thing and i
think after we had done our set or maybe
no was it before or after we were done i
said it was after we had done our set
some guys came to say while going to say
hello and then he went straight to jimmy
and said yo you're not 5 11. you're the
same highest few had and man said go
back to back right now fam go back to
back right now and prove that you're not
couldn't believe the chest the chest the
audacity
and he actually had hands on [ __ ] yes
and i remember you your initial reaction
was to go like this yeah [ __ ] it then
and i was like don't you turn around
do not turn around don't add fuel to the
fire any guy telling you to
to turn your back he wasn't sending it
for me i couldn't care less i wanted to
smack him in his
face did
who the [ __ ] are you bro i must say go
back to back now
i said right now i couldn't believe it
oh that was hilarious leave me alone
that was hilarious i'm hoping the the
yeah the more i don't claim six foot the
more people just leave me alone yeah
because it's just ridiculous
the height is that women are are
actually causing ruckus between mandem
which doesn't make sense but then you've
got people like jay that's six four yeah
and he doesn't he just looks down and
sees ants yeah he doesn't
he never looks at fema or on social
everyone thinks i wonder how tall she is
he never looks and thinks oh she looks
tall he doesn't cross his mind i would
never cross his mind because he's so far
gone unless she's [ __ ] tall even if
she's not because like i'm trying to
think people like to think that being
tall as a woman is only a direct
insecurity of a man
and they like to think they're like oh
if you're a tall man you don't care
about a tall woman but you do
because
some women are [ __ ] tall like
tall yeah that's it even if my boy was
six six and he's dating a girl that's
like six one that's fam i'll still pull
him down and be like
pull him down
quick
she's very pretty she's [ __ ] tall
what are we doing
james this
yo let me talk to you real quick
fam come go go go go
i'm on his toes
just to catch a ear let me talk to you
real quick
yo
pull him down and say fam she seems like
a lovely girl but she's [ __ ] tall
what are we doing
what where's the line you can't throw
about nuts yeah what are you man doing
in there
what are you man doing in there
[ __ ] hell but yeah bro that's
hilarious that video is is torment
i promise you now i would walk off if in
that situation these man it's just like
yeah well we've got a tape measure here
that's nice
yeah i would challenge him
i'll look down measure yourself measure
yourself first and i'll measure me i'll
follow yeah i'll be straight on him how
tall are you chat about i've got a tape
measure you're the shortest guy i've
seen
you get so defensive
so different people put me in a corner
i lash
[Laughter]
everything could be hanky dory until
someone says something like i've got a
tape measure square up i'll send for him
he won't know what's up guys thank you
very much for listening that was a short
clip from our most recent patreon
episode um if you enjoyed it and you
want to get the full episode head on
over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
link is in the description and once
you're there it's going to cost you a
light humble three pound a month tempe a
day run the p you know the drills head
on over today guys and enjoy thank you
very much
[Music]
you